[Musik]
befindet sich mitten in einem möglichen
dritten Bürgerkrieg seit seiner
Unabhängigkeit in einem Land das
traditionell vom Militär dominiert wird
toben seit Mitte April wieder Kämpfe
ziel war es die Kontrolle über kartum
die sudanesische Hauptstadt zu
übernehmen die Truppen des General für
das Land regierte standen der Miliz
gegenüber die von dem damaligen
Vizepräsidenten angeführt wurde wir
haben damals bereits in einem Video
darüber berichtet in den folgenden
Monaten setzten sich die Kämpfe Fort
kaktum wurde verwüstet und die Gewalt
hat sich nun auf andere Teil des du dann
ausgeweitet die dortige Lage nimmt die
Züge eines ethnischen Konflikts an der
äußerst besorgniserregend wird im Moment
gibt es keine verlässlichen Zahlen aber
alles Leute darauf hin dass die Zahl der
Todesopfer bereits über 10.000 liegt
außerdem führten die Kämpfe zu
Vertreibung von mehr als 4 Millionen
Menschen und einige von euch werden
jetzt vielleicht denken okay dass du
daran ist weit weg und hier in Europa
gibt es schon genug Krieg warum sollte
mich das groß interessieren nun lasst
mich euch eines versichern dass du daran
ist wichtiger als ihr denkt und seit
kurzem hat er auch viel mehr mit dem
russischen Krieg in der Ukraine zu tun
als sich viele vorstellen konnten am
Ende dieses Videos hattet ihr genau
verstehen wieso der Krieg in der Ukraine
auch im Sudan entschieden wird aber
eines nach dem anderen schauen wir uns
erstmal die Lage des Sudan an
ähnlich groß wie Mexiko ist der Sudan
das drittgrößte Land Afrikas und war vor
der Unabhängigkeit der Südsudans sogar
das größte Land des afrikanischen
Kontinents er ist strategisch äußerst
günstig gelegen da seine Küste Zugang
zum Roten Meer hat durch das etwa 10%
des Welthandels auf dem Seeweg
abgewickelt werden außerdem verfügt er
über bedeutende natürliche Ressourcen
zum einen gibt es Ölvorkommen der hast
du dann schwimmt zwar nicht gerade eben
dinosaft hat aber eine bescheidene
erdölproduktionesische Rohstoff der
jedoch überall steht ist ein Edelmetall
und im Sudan gibt es so viel Gold das
sogar eine Rohstoff groß macht nämlich
Russland bzw die wagnergruppe darauf
aufmerksam geworden sind die Wagner
sollen haben Verbindungen zu einem Sudan
kämpfenden Fraktion gebildet und machen
mit ihren Goldbeständen ordentlich
Profit aber wie wir alle wissen ist
Wagner bossin mittlerweile tot und die
Dinge sind verdammt kompliziert geworden
mittlerweile scheint es total Konflikt
gar zu Stellvertreter der Krieg zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine geworden zu
sein sozusagen zu einem erweiterten
Kriegsschauplatz über das europäische
Schlachtfeld hinaus die 20 September
2023 ukrainische Spezialeinheiten
stecken wahrscheinlich hinter den
Angriffen auf die von Wagner
unterstützten Kräfte im Sudan
ukrainische Spezialkräfte stecken
wahrscheinlich hinter einer Reihe von
Drohnenangriffen und einer
bodenoperation gegen eine von Wagner
unterstützte Miliz in der Nähe des
sudanesischen Hauptstadt die Operation
umfasst eine Reihe von Angriffen auf die
parameterische Gruppe Support forces RSF
die vermutlich von der russischen Gruppe
Wagner in ihrem Kampf gegen die
sudanesische Armee um die Kontrolle des
Landes unterstützt wird Videomaterial
zeigt die Merkmale von Drohnenangriff
nach ukrainischen Vorbild verdeckte
Angriffe der Ukraine im Sudan würden
eine dramatische und provokative
Ausweitung des Krieg schon Platz ist
gegen Moskau bedeuten
und als ob das alles nicht genug wäre
herrscht im Sudan auch noch ein Konflikt
zwischen zwei traditionell Verbündeten
Ländern die Rede ist von Saudi-Arabien
und den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
die nämlich unterschiedliche Seiten
unterstützen aber über seine
geostrategische Bedeutung hinaus sollte
man sich mit dem Sudan natürlich auch
deswegen befassen da sich dort ein
absolut grausamer Krieg entwickeln
könnte und ihr wisst das Konflikt in
Afrika dazu neigen zu einem Blutbad zu
eskalieren
UN-Generalsekretär antonia cutes hat
bereits die Alarmglocken läuten lassen
Konflikt Kennwort schon
identitis
the gameti ihr seht also egal ob es das
geostrategische oder humanitäre
Interesse ist man sollte wissen was im
Sudan genau vor sich geht die Fragen
lauten daher warum ist in Sudan ein so
brutaler Konflikt überhaupt ausgebrochen
welche Interessen verfolgen die
verschiedenen Mächte die hinter beiden
Seiten stehen und was könnte in den
kommenden Monaten passieren in unserem
heutigen Video werden wir natürlich all
diese Fragen beantworten und zwar wie so
oft in den wird zunächst einen schnellen
Blick auf die Geschichte werfen bevor
wir uns jedoch ins Afrika des 19
Jahrhunderts begeben habe ich euch noch
eine frohe Botschaft zu überbringen das
heutige Video hat übrigens in kognie
möglich gemacht ein Sponsor der euch
aktiv vor einer anderen Misere schützen
kann dem Datenmissbrauch durch
sogenannte data Broker das sind
datenmakler die unsere persönlichen
Daten über alle Netz abgreifen und
danach nicht nur ein seriöse Unternehmen
verkaufen sondern auch ein Betrüger
diese Betrüger bombardieren uns dann mit
unerwünschten Anrufen SMS und E-Mails
oder versuchen uns da auszunehmen leider
haben wir keine Kontrolle darüber an wen
unsere Daten verkauft werden aber die
data Broker sind gesetzlich dazu
verpflichtet unsere Daten zu löschen
wenn wir sie dazu auffordern das Problem
dabei es gibt Tausende von ihnen oft ist
der Antragsprozess wesentlich
kompliziert gestaltet deswegen
resignieren viele Menschen einfach und
lassen den ganzen Schmuck passiv über
sich ergehen Herr Sponsor dieses Videos
inkognit bietet jedoch genau hierfür
eine Lösung inkognit übernimmt die
Aufgabe bei den data Brokern aufzuräumen
und die Löschanträge zu stellen um uns
vor Betrugsversuchen zu schützen du
meldest dich einfach bei inkognit an
beauftragt sie in deinem Namen die
lösch-einträge durchzusetzen und
verfolgst dann bequem auf eine
übersichtlichen Dashboard wie deine
Daten nach und nach aus dem Netz
verschwinden ohne einen solchen Service
wäre es für einen normalen Menschen
nahezu unmöglich diese lösch-anträge
selbst zu bearbeiten und sich vor Betrug
zu schützen also du was gutes für deine
datenhygiene und schau dir in KODi über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung an
außerdem mit dem Promo Code politik.de
erhältst du auch noch 60% Rabatt wenn du
zu den ersten 100 gehörst die nutzen so
und wenn ihr das erledigt habt und dann
wieder hier seid lasst uns ins
historische Ägypten reisen das damals
Teil des Osmanischen Reiches war dort
finden sich nämlich die Anfänge des
modernen also aufgepasst
[Musik]
Dämonen zu Pferd
im frühen 19 jahrhundert eroberten die
Herstellers osmanischen Ägyptens das
Gebiet das heute dem größten Teil des
Sudans entspricht erst 1899 wurde das
Sudan ein Herrschaftsgebiet des
britischen Weltreichs diese Kolonie
erlangte dann 1956 ihre Unabhängigkeit
und viele von euch werden sagen na das
waren ja tolle Neuigkeiten für die
Sudanesen wie schön dass Sie Ihre
Zukunft von nun an selbstbestimmen
konnten indem sie eine Demokratie wurden
nun leider muss ich euch da enttäuschen
denn das war nicht der Fall
wärst du daran ist nämlich das
afrikanische Land mit der zweifelhaften
Ehre während seiner kurzen Geschichte
die meisten Staatsstreiche auf dem
Kontinent erlebt zu haben und dass man
lieben Zuschauer will in Afrika schon
was heißen seit seiner Unabhängigkeit
haben sage und schreibe 16 Kutsche
stattgefunden von den sechs erfolgreich
waren auf diese Weise haben die Militärs
nämlich drei Versuche zu Etablierung
eine Demokratie im Land unterbunden den
letzten Jahren 2021 dass du daran hat zu
allem Überfluss aber auch noch zwei
brutale Bürgerkriege erlebt von denen
der eine 17 Jahre oder andere
zweiundzwanzig Jahre andauerte der
Konflikte im April ausbrach könnte sich
potentiell also zu einem drittensischen
Bürgerkrieg entwickeln
und ja ihr habt richtig gehört von den
67 Jahren die die Republik Sudan
überhaupt besteht haben sie 39 Jahre
lang gegeneinander gekämpft also mehr
als die Hälfte der Zeit es handelt es
sich um den Kampf des zuzugans einen
unabhängigen Staat mit einer
mehrheitlich christlichen Bevölkerung zu
schaffen während der Rest des
ursprünglichen Landes in wesentlich
muslimisch war schließlich erlangten die
Südsudanesen im Jahr 2011 ihre
Unabhängigkeit sie nahmen 25% des
Territoriums und 75 % der Ölreserven mit
allerdings unter der Vereinbarung diesen
reicht du auch mit dem Norden zu teilen
doch diese Ressourcen haben den jüngsten
Land der Welt nur wenig benutzt denn
große Überraschung in den 12 Jahren
seiner Unabhängigkeit hat das zuzuladen
bereits einen siebenjährigen Bürgerkrieg
hinter sich aber warte mal denn die
beiden Bürgerkriege sind nur ein Teil
des unternehmensischen drei Könige es
gibt da nämlich noch den davor Konflikt
so nannte ihn der damalige
UN-Generalsekretär Kopie einander im
Jahr 2006
die schlimmste humanitäre Krise der Welt
1989 kam general Omar al Basir im Sudan
an die Macht er regierte das Land 30
Jahre lang und errichtete eine Diktatur
die von kartum aus von einer islamischen
Elite beherrscht wurde in den Randregion
des Landes sahen die Dinge jedoch anders
aus in der Region davor lebten
schwarzafrikanische Volksgruppen die
hauptsächlich in der Landwirtschaft
tätig waren wie die fuhr dieser gABA und
die zusammen mit den arabischen
Bevölkerung die sich der Weidewirtschaft
widmete die Viehzüchter und die Bauern
kämpften regelmäßig gegeneinander um
Territorien und im Jahr 2003 begannen
die amerikanischen Volksgruppen aufgrund
ihrer Vernachlässigung durch die
Zentralbank um einen Aufstand ja und war
schier mobilisierte daraufhin die Armee
bevor er sich dann noch an die Ganja
David wandte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bedeutet Dämonen zu Pferd und ist der
Name der Miliz die von der
sultanesischen Regierung zur
Aufstandsbekämpfung gegen ethnische
Afrikaner eingesetzt wird aber
angesichts der geringen Fortschritte
dieser Streitkräfte bewaffnete baschier
arabische Nomaden und ließ sie auf
schwarzafrikanische Bauern los was
folgte war eine brutale ethnische
Säuberung also ein erbarmungsloser
Völkermarkt 300.000 Menschen wurden
getötet und bis zu 2,7 Millionen aus
ihren Häusern vertrieben
[Musik]
und woher kommt meistens so einen
Staatsstreich natürlich aus dem eigenen
Militär um sich also vor seinen eigenen
Streitkräften zu schützen hat Bashir die
chancia Wied offiziell in seine
persönliche Prätorianergarde umgewandelt
voila geboren waren die schnellen
Unterstützungskräfte die Rapid Support
Force das kurz rssf merkt euch dieses
große sehr gut RSS und als Befehlshaber
der Rapper Support setzte er seine
rechte Hand Mohammed haben dann da Gallo
ein bei der Gallo handelt es sich um
eine erfahrenen Warlord der sich selbst
hamitin nennt hamiti wiederum steht für
Klein Mohammed und vielleicht war das ja
der Grund warum marschiert die großen
Ambitionen der Gallos nicht erkannte
niemand ist gerne die Krümel von einem
festen mal jeder sitzt gerne mit am
Tisch einzudonesische Sprichwort
international isoliert verschlechterte
sich die Lage dass du danesischen
Wirtschaft zunehmends Knappheit und
Armut grassierten es sollte ein
Volksaufstand nach dem anderen und im
April 2019 schienen die Aufständischen
ihr Ziel erreicht zu haben
wirklich zu stürzen brauchte es ja ihr
habt es erraten einen Staatsstreich die
generelle versetzten basiert den letzten
Stoß als sie sahen dass seine Diktatur
dem Tode geweiht war und hamiti
unterstütze den Putsch baschier war
nämlich auch für ihn entbehrlich
geworden das Problem nachdem die Armee
und passiers eigene Leibgarde so gut
zusammengearbeitet haben um ihn zu
beseitigen verkrachten sie sich wieder
denn wieder die Streitkräfte noch Hamit
die waren bereit ihre privilegierte
Stellung in Sudan zu verlieren und wie
wir hier bei visualpolitik sagen gesagt
getan und als oberster general als
Anführer des neuen regierungsorgans
vereidigt general wurde zum
Staatsoberhaupt ist total ernannt indem
er den Vorsitz im neuen souveränenrad
übernahmen und dieser stellte ihm hamiti
als Vizepräsident zur Seite denn
natürlich kann man den Mann der die
Ganja Beat eine bewaffnete Truppe von
100.000 Soldaten anführt nicht einfach
beiseiteschieben tja und für dich oder
lesen war das alles nicht gerade ein
Grund zum Feiern das Volk hatte sich
nicht gegen Bashir erhoben um den St
ATuS quo beizubehalten also schloss das
Militär einen Pakt mit der zivilführung
sie würden sich die Macht vorerst teilen
und zwar bis zum März 2022 wenn Wahlen
abgehalten werden sollten ich meine was
konnte bei diesen Voraussetzungen und
der Erfolgsbilanz des Sudans beim
Übergang zur Demokratie schon schief
gehen ja er hat es erraten im Grunde
alles schaut euch an
der schattenstart versus der
afrikanische Kriegerin
das Abkommen über die Teilung der Macht
zwischen der Zivilregierung und den
Militär im Jahr 2019 war äußerst fragil
und was war der Hauptgrund nun es gibt
vielleicht Länder die wesentlich reicher
sind als das Sudan aber es gibt nur sehr
wenige in denen man sich auf demselben
Niveau bereichern kann wenn man an der
Macht ist nur mal so zur
Veranschaulichung beim ehemaligen
Diktator hatte man 130 Milliarden Dollar
in bar in seinem Haus gefunden ganz
genau 130 Millionen in bar und er
kontrollierte die sudanesische
Wirtschaft über das Militär deswegen
sind natürlich auch die anderen Generäle
nicht gerade mit los als die neue zivile
Regierung also eine Maß an Transparenz
und rechenschaftspflichten anstrebte
dass er zukünftigen im Sudan
angestrebten Demokratie würde ich war
wusste general vorhanden genau was er zu
tun hatte und nein er war dabei nicht
alleine
die tritt aus dem Schatten hervor und
unterstützt vor Hans Putsch westliche
Geldgeber und multilaterale Banken
hatten Milliarden von Dollar zugesagt um
den demokratischen Übergang zu
unterstützen doch der Putsch von General
bohrhahn und hameti im Oktober 2021
verhinderte das ein Großteil dieser
Hilfen den Sudan erreichte
[Musik]
die USA die Weltbank und der
Internationale Währungsfonds stoppt den
Fluss von mindestens 1,4 Milliarden
Dollar an Hilfen und Schulden erlassen
für den Sudan musste daraufhin die
Subventionen für Weizen und Treibstoff
kürzen die Situation
ist nicht in der Lage sich selbst zu
ernähren das Militär war also gezwungen
erneut mit den zivilen Politikern zu
verhandeln um den demokratischen
Übergang doch noch voranzutreiben und
den vergangenen Dezember erzielten sie
eine Einigung Sudan will am 11 April
eine neue zivilgeführte
Übergangsregierung einsetzen das große
Problem bei diesen Vereinbarungen mit
dem Militär ist jedoch dass sie eine
Menge zu verbergen haben general
bohrhahn will das schützen was
unternesische Demokraten den Schatten
Staaten nennen damit ist ein ganzes
Netzwerk von Unternehmen gemeint von
Banken und Kommunikationsunternehmen die
sich im Besitz von Islamisten und
Geheimdienstmitarbeitern befinden bis
hin zu Firmen die den Streitkräften
selbst gehören und Wirtschaftssektoren
wie die Waffenherstellung des Bauwesen
die Landwirtschaft und das
Transportwesen beherrschen und ähnliches
kann man auch über Hamidi sagen den
letzten Jahren zum afrikanischen
geworden ist
mit dem Unterschied dass er noch lebt
hamiti ist nämlich viel mehr als nur ein
Warlord Diktator basiert überließ den
Kontrolle über die illegalen Goldmine
des Landes insbesondere in der Region
davor was Hamidi zu einem der reichsten
Männer des Landes gemacht hat er hat
aber außerdem noch viel mehr Geld und
Verbündete gewonnen indem er seine
schnellen Unterstützungskräfte als
Zöllner in dieser der Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate eingesetzt hat um im
Jemen gegen die Rebellen und in Libyen
an der Seite von General Khalifa hat zu
kämpfen
das neue übergangsabkommen wie ist die
beiden mächtigsten Männer des Sudan
jedoch in die Schranken die Bedingungen
waren klar dass Sudan würde über eine
einzige Armee unter dem Kommando der
zivilen Regierung verfügen und die
schnellen Unterstützungskräfte RSF
müssten in diese integriert werden ja
und ihr wisst schon ganz genau was jetzt
kommt denn diese Vereinbarung bedrohte
eindeutig die privilegierte Position bei
der Parteien zum einen die von General
bohanna das Abkommen demokratische
Wahlen für 2024 vorsah zum anderen
natürlich die von hamiti innerhalb von
zwei Jahren muss er seine Miliz in die
Armee integrieren und das wollte er wie
sein russischer counterpartikeln so weit
wie möglich hinauszögern erforderte eine
Übergangszeit von mindestens einem
Jahrzehnt die jedoch von der
zivildregierung abgelehnt wurde der
einzige Ausblick für beide war also der
bewaffnete Kampf um zu sehen wer von
beiden über die Zukunft des Sudans
entscheiden würde und so bekam zunächst
die Hauptstadt des Landes die Hauptplatz
des Konflikts zu spüren die Straßen von
Karton sind durch den militärischen
Konflikt verwüstet ja und wisst ihr was
bei diesen Bürgerkrieg eigentlich das
größte Problem ist nun so zynisch ist
auch klingenmark das ist ein
ausgeglichener Kampf ist es wird nämlich
für beide Seiten extrem schwierig sein
sich durchzusetzen die offiziellen
sudanesischen Streitkräfte sind nicht
viel wert aber sie verfügen über
Flugzeuge
gerade der beste Freund des
unternehmensischen Demokraten ist und zu
all dem kommt dass die Unterstützung
durch ausländische Mächte des
Gleichgewicht doch noch in die eine oder
andere Richtung klingt könnte denn wie
ihr gleich sehen werdet stehen für diese
im Sudan verdammt viele eigene
Interessen auf dem Spiel von welchen
Interessen der sprechen und das werden
wir uns jetzt genau ansehen aufgepasst
[Musik]
der Schatz im Roten Meer
die wichtigsten Mächte am Roten Meer
sind Saudi-Arabien und Ägypten es ist
daher in Ihrem Interesse den Status Quo
in der Region aufrecht zu erhalten das
gilt natürlich auch für den Sudan vor
allem nach dem Sturz der basilikatur die
sich ihren Rivalen Türkei und Katar
stark angenähert hatte Saudi Arabien und
Ägypten waren mit der Militär Kunter von
hemet die einverstanden ihr Hauptziel im
Sudan war es eine demokratische
Revolution in der arabischen Welt zu
verhindern deshalb unterstützen Sie dazu
nachbarsch hier Saudi Arabien hat zu
gesagt 3 Milliarden Dollar zu
investieren aber Moment mal in die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate haben den
Einsatz verdoppelt und was ist der Grund
für dieses große Interesse nun das Rote
Meer gibt uns die Antwort
Vereinigte Arabische Emirate bauen Hafen
im Sudan als Teil eines 6 Milliarden
Dollar investitionspakets obwohl sie
traditionell Verbündete sind ist der
Hafen des Emirates WE der Saudi-Arabien
noch für Ägypten von Interesse außerdem
ist deriat Favorit general Burhan der
aufgrund der engen Beziehungen zwischen
des sudanesischen und der ägyptischen
Armee auch der Favorit von General alcc
ist aber wie ich euch bereits gesagt
habe meine Lieben Zuschauer ist der Mann
der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate im
Sudan hemeti und all diese sich
überschneidenden Interessen stehen im
Einklang mit der Strategie Abu Dhabis es
verfolgt das Ziel sein wirtschaftliches
Potenzial voll auszuschöpfen um nämlich
Saudi-Arabien als das Maß aller Dinge in
der arabischen Welt Konkurrenz zu machen
[Musik]
während Prinz bin Salman nach dem Mord
an kaschogi im Westen in unglade
gefallen ist haben die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate versucht sich als das
für freundliche Gesicht der Region
darzustellen am Ende haben sie vor allem
im Jemen und in Washington andere
Interessen gezeigt als Abu Dhabi
versuchte Riad als Amerikas bevorzugten
militärischen Verbündeten am Gold
abzulösen
doch bin Salman scheut die Konfrontation
mit den Rivalen am Golf nicht er
versucht nun verlorenen Boden wieder gut
zu machen wir können dies zum Beispiel
gut auf sportlicher Ebene beobachten was
ich damit meine nun die Emirate kaufen
Manchester City also kauften die Sonys
Newcastle in Abu Dhabi gibt es die
Formel 1 also muss es die Formel 1 nun
auch in Saudi-Arabien geben und so
weiter und so fort aber um noch einmal
auf den Krieg im Sudan zurückzukommen
die Priorität der Regionalmächte liegt
im Moment nicht so sehr auf den Frieden
sondern darauf dass die von ihnen
unterstützte Seite die Oberhand gewinnt
das gilt umso mehr wenn wir die
wagnergruppe in die Gleichung
einbeziehen das Gold das hamiti im Sudan
bekommt wird über die Emirate nach
Russland geschmuggelt das Weiße Haus hat
eine Weile gebraucht aber sie haben nun
endlich einen Schritt gegen Abu Dhabi
unternommen schaut euch an zwei
waffenfirmen die das Unternehmen
verbunden sind wurden von den USA
sanktioniert inzwischen wurden auch
altonaid ein von Hermetik und seinem
Bruder kontrolliertes
goldhandelsunternehmen und das in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
anlässige Unternehmen credit
sanktioniert die Verbindung in der Wagen
der Gruppe zu Hamed die reichen bis ins
Jahr 2017 zurück
[Musik]
im Prinzip hatte Wagner den
Aufständischen RSF Waffen und
militärische Ausbildung im Austausch für
den Zugang zu sudanesischem Gold geboten
wir haben damals darüber bereits ein
Video gedreht und nun könnten wir ein
weiteres drehen wie Russland seinen
Einfluss in Afrika ausweitet aber nach
pregorians molterei und als Zerschlagung
Wagners hat sich das Szenario geändert
ja oder vielleicht doch nicht so sehr
denn wenn der kremme die von Wagner
errichteten Allianzen aufrecht erhalten
will wie auf dem Gipfel mit
afrikanischen Führern der christlichen
St Petersburg statt von demonstriert
braucht er die alten Strukturen Wagners
und vor allem die goldströme
russlandwirtschaft wird durch den
deutschen Vogel der Wagen der Gruppe
gestützt so ein Berichte britischen
Regierung das sudanistische Gold ist für
den Kreml einfach zu attraktiv als das
er eretti fallen lassen würde allerdings
stellt sich die Frage inwieweit Putin
nach der Tötung des wagner-boses
trikotin und der allgemeinen Schwächung
der russischen macht noch weiterhin in
der Lage sein wird sein Verbündeten
nicht nur zu unterstützen sondern auch
bei Laune zu halten gerade als wir
dieses aufgenommen hatten tauchten
Gerüchte auf das bregorian Sohn die
Söldnertruppe anführen soll und dies
scheint eher daraufhin zu deuten dass
die Übernahme der Truppe durch neue
vertraute Putins und scheuburg wohl
nicht ganz der reibungslos klappt ja und
zu all dem kommen dann noch Nachrichten
wie diese
militärische Aufklärung sudanschlag
gegen Wagner signalisiert Russland
schwindenden Einfluss in Afrika aus all
dem wird immer mehr deutlich dass die
Ukraine zur Schwächung des russischen
kriegspotentials eine wirklich
ausgeklügelte und vor allem globale
Strategie führt und sich mittlerweile
auch nicht vor Interventionen schaut wie
wir sie normalerweise von Großmächten
gewohnt sind eine wirklich
beeindruckende Entwicklung in diesem
Fall geht es eben darum die Ausbeutung
afrikanischer Goldminen zur Finanzierung
der chemischen Kriegsmaschine zu
unterbinden in den kieft die Feinde
Moskau unterstützt und das sowohl im
Sudan als auch mittlerweile in Mali
woran erhält nämlich zudem gute
Unterstützung durch Saudi Arabien das im
Jahr 2022 den 5 größten Militärhaushalt
der Welt hatte hinter den USA China
Russland und Indien es deutet also alles
darauf hin dass sich der Krieg im Sudan
weiterhin ziehen wird und das alle
weiterhin Öl in ihn Gießen werden wir
werden die Lage deswegen genau
beobachten und euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden halten vergesst also bitte
nicht das aber unbedingt mit glücklich
und keines unserer Videos zu verpassen
und in der Zwischenzeit sind die Fragen
an ausgerichtet was glaubt ihr wie sich
die Situation im Sudan noch entwickeln
wird wird eine der ausländischen Mächte
direkt involviert sein schreibt uns eure
Einschätzung in den Kommentarbereich und
vergesst bitte auch nicht auf meinem
neuen Kanal vorbeizuschauen den ich euch
ebenfalls in der Videobeschreibung
verlinkt habe falls euch Themen wie
dieses aus einer etwas anderen
Perspektive interessieren ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt es bitte ein Like Teil mit
euren Freunden und diskutiert ist auch
mit ihnen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr ebenfalls in der
Videobeschreibung macht's gut und bis
bald
[Musik]